I'mma go ahead and and try someone else
man to see if they can if they want to
contribute all right all right man how
can I do this you stupid bro
wow manifest bro that's manifesting at
his
finest hey
[Applause]
bring hey what you do what you do he was
talking to me yeah Oh I thought he said
life you stupid you said I mean you're
stupid damn guess I'm stupid according
to you Muslims the law is all powerful
but apparently when we're reading a
verse verbatim and we're interpreting it
correctly we're the stupid ones but you
guys can't read what's up habbi what up
bro much hey have you been uh in the
conversation a little bit I just got in
like five minutes ago okay
so problem is that what verse does it
say that he needs a son or he needs a
wife to have a son chapter 6 verse 1
I understand I understand your argument
about what you're trying to make but the
way it's being said is if he were to
have a mate who would his mate be so if
he has how could he have a children if
he has no mate there's no one no mate
there to begin with so therefore he no
therefore he could still create things
but it's not saying it's just basically
saying there was never any mate for him
to create any children or to make
children if he's God alone then he's
able to create anything except a son so
God didn't create you I'm not his I'm
not Allah's son right I'm his creation
but not his son right that's what I'm
saying but the question is about sunship
what happened the question is about
sunship can Allah have a son not can he
create people right but my my point is
is everybody in the human race is a
creation of God so and the sons of God
no there's no Son of God that's what
we're talking about we're talking about
Sons what does he need in order that
what does he need in order to have a son
according to that
verse the point the verse is trying to
make is in the history of all the
biblical in the history of all the
biblical Quran abrahamic religions when
has God ever had a m never all right
then so the point I'm trying to guess
what wait guess what don't do it
according to all Biblical history and
all biblical writings God is able to
have a son without a without a mate
according to Quran the New Testament or
Old Testament both okay was the Bible
created by brother don't do this huh
yeah
don't do this don't do this stay focused
stay focus okay hey hey life you don't
get banned bro because you're in the car
just let go ahead what you were saying
I'm
serious nice now we got all the brothers
on cam that's what I'm now now I'm
afraid to get banned bro I ain't gonna
hold you br so have to go off I mean I
don't get like that anyway so
sorry for for according to the Quran in
order for Allah to have a son what does
he need it's not saying he needs
anything he's saying there's no there
was no mate to begin with he has no mate
and which means that he doesn't have so
when he doesn't because he doesn't have
a mate therefore he doesn't have what I
understand what you trying to say you're
but you're taking the the sentence out
of context well I'm actually taking it
in context they're accusing they're
attributing Sons and Daughters to Allah
and Allah's response to them is
reputation to their claims that he has
children is that he doesn't have a
partner so if he had a partner then they
could make the case that he has children
because he has a partner but because he
has no partner it's impossible for them
to make the case that he has a son
because that's what he needs to have a
son okay so we can both agree that he
has no partner and if that's something
God would need to have a son then
wouldn't that debunk the whole thing of
him having a son if there's no mate to
begin with and islamically yes
islamically because Allah needs a mate
to have a son it and he doesn't have a
mate he doesn't have a companion it
doesn't say that means okay so for
example let's let's let's let's do this
I I I've use this example I think it's
the easiest one for us to understand if
I say how can I drive the car when I
don't have the keys what according to
that sentence what do I need in order to
drive the car okay I understand where
you're going but let's just say my
answer no already know the answer is the
keys obviously but what now let's just
say the car was all powerful was able to
do anything creative everything and the
car didn't need keys to create or the
car is all powerful and the Crea
everything it's an example though you're
missing you're you're missing the
analogy I'm I'm the person I'm the user
not the car so car the Oba okay I and as
as you said so I'm I'm supposed to be
the all powerful one all right so
imagine I am all powerful would I need
keys in order to drive the car if I'm
all powerful say that again my fa that
cut out if I'm all powerful would I
need keys in order to drive the car no
putting you in the same category as God
no if I'm all powerful so it wouldn't
make sense for me to say how can I drive
the car when I don't have the keys if
I'm all powerful right because I don't
need keys let's put it like this to
drive like this because the way you just
explained it you're you're now factoring
yourself in the in the thing so now
let's just say the car for example would
be got please I I need you please stick
with the example and and and let's deal
with this I'm I'm stick with the example
listen Okay so please stick with what I
just asked because you're not answering
okay so now I gotta hold you down to it
if I'm all powerful would it make sense
for me to say how can I drive the car
when I don't have the keys will it make
sense for me to say that if I'm all
powerful I understand but no it wouldn't
make sense thank you because the
sentence entails that I need the keys to
drive the car which mean I'm not all
powerful if I need the keys right okay
so same sentence same phrase same
phraseology just now substituting the
characters in Allah who's supposed to be
all powerful says this how can he have a
son when he doesn't have a companion so
if Allah's all powerful it does not make
sense for him to ask that question it
doesn't all right so would he wouldn't
need a partner to have a son he could
just do it by himself I get your point I
get your point okay so this shows that
not all powerful if we're talking about
logically that that would make sense but
now let's let's just say it's got logic
baby I understand but now let's just say
the keys were never in the picture the
car starts whenever you want it to start
or like you know the car doesn't need
the keys never needed the keys to begin
with all right so that being said if the
if the car is quote unquote God for
example the car is not God man I'm I'm
the come on listen let me finish what
I'm saying go ahead I just
using this analogy if the car never
needed the keys to begin with the
argument would be why why would he need
the keys in the first place who's the he
in your analogy that would make that
would make Allah that would make Allah
ignorant because if he's all knowing he
wouldn't ask a question like that so
you're saying that the car is keyless
AKA pushed to start well then he
wouldn't ask the question of how can I
drive the car without the keys because
then he would already know and it would
literally just be a dum question so it
wouldn't that that wouldn't even make
any sense in comparison the question is
not for Allah the questions for human
kind the human race it's a reputation to
the human race do you understand so
elaborate that a little bit more then
okay so for example imagine if someone
accused me of driving this particular
car they accused me of driving this car
they said Avery you drove this car and
my response to them is what how can I
drive that car when I don't have the
keys which takes the if since I don't
have the keys it takes any possibility
of me driving that car you know it takes
away any possibility of that happening
because I don't have the keys so I'm I'm
answering I'm I'm refuting the
accusations against me the claims that I
drove the car so similarly Allah is
refuting the claims of these polytheists
that he has children you have children
Allah you have sons and daughters his
response is what how can I have son a
son when I don't have a wife when I
don't have a companion
so not having a compion takes out
possibility of him having it's aut to
their claim okay but now if we go to the
Bible when they say that why are we
going to the Bible is I'm just saying
because they they do mentioned in the
Bible that Jesus is somewhere in there
that he's God's only begotten son we can
go we can go there we can go there a
little bit bro but first let's complete
this let's complete this and then we can
go into Christian Theology and show you
what what it means for Jesus be begotten
son and all that how that works I I
promise we can go into that first let's
conclude on this okay so so do you see
how you see what the problem is like
with this statement or question that
Allah is using as a reputation to the
people saying that he has a CH that he
has children he's showing that he in
order for him to have children he would
need a partner in the first place but he
has no partner he's above having a
partner there's nobody like him there's
no one in the vicinity like him so
therefore because no one like that
exists he can't have a son okay so how
do you make babies bro with a partner
all right then God has already claimed
that he doesn't have any children if
there's no M involved there's no reason
for him to have a mate to mate children
well okay there's if he doesn't have a
mate then he doesn't have the ability to
have children right not true not if he's
all powerful he's God bro I see you're
you'rein you're misin I love the you
brought I love the example that you
brought up if in order to have children
we need a partner humans do at least
right and then you correlated that with
Allah if he doesn't have a partner
there's no point of children well it's
not just simply that there's no point of
children it's that he can't have
children but you're saying no but he
could if he's all powerful I agree which
is why this particular verse shows that
he's not all powerful and he's not God
by default because he needs a partner to
have a CH a kid but that's not you're
misinterpreting it bro it's not he's not
saying he needs a mate the the sentence
is saying that the basically saying
there was no mate to begin with that's
not what it says that's not what it says
no that's not what it says but that's
that's how you're supposed to interpret
it there was no let's keep doing it this
way I'm going to give you a few more
examples let's see if any of these
examples It lines up with with how
you're trying to understand it okay we
already did the keys example let's do
another one how can I plant the tree
when I don't have land according to my
sentence what do I need in order to
plant the tree seeds and land thank you
so I need land to plant the tree let's
do another example um how can I walk the
dog when I don't have a leash so
according to my sentence what do I need
in order to walk the dog Le beautiful
let me put it this way if I said how can
I have a son when I don't have a wife
according to the sentence what do I need
in order to have a son I understand what
you're saying
but
come there's no there's no way he just
did that bro but I
can right now I'm looking at the verse
in my my physical finish it finish it I
said it I said it it's you need a
wife but nowhere in the Quran says he
needs a wife it doesn't say he needs a
wife and and nowhere and guess what how
in in the sentence that I that I just
structured did I say did it come out of
my mouth that I need did the word need
come out my my mouth uh that I need a
wife to have a son did that come out my
mouth you're claiming though that the
Quran says he needs a wife to have a son
did did I say out of my own mouth that I
need a wife to have a son did that did I
say that I mean I don't I honestly don't
even recall to be honest all right so
I'll repeat it it's okay that's fair
I'll repeat it the sentence goes like
this again how can I have a son when I
don't have a wife now according to that
sentence what do I need in order to have
a son right you need a wife but the way
you're saying it is more so like did I
did I say that I need a wife like how
can I have a son if I don't got a wife
that's how you saying it that's not
that's not the context of the Quran did
I onbi did it come out of my mouth that
I need a wife did I say I need a wife no
no I didn't but you understand from the
phrase of the sentence that I'm saying
that I need a wife in order to have a
son by the structure of my senses when I
say how can I how can I do this if I
don't have this that means I'm saying I
need this in order to do this so just
like how you understood from my sentence
that I need a wife in order to have a
son you got to be consistent Allah I
just repeated the verse that's all I did
is repeat the verse
so Allah needs a wife based on that
sentence Allah needs a wife in order to
have a son is he trying to claim that
Allah is
basically uh implementing a
thought-provoking question no he's not
what is he then what is he then what is
he claiming then because he say let's
see let's see it seems like we might we
might have gotten somewhere just now I
don't know let's let's let this simmer
all I didn't remember you're logically
speaking what you saying makes sense
but that's not how the Quan is producing
that
sence didn't is it meaning because we're
going in circles now what what what you
tell us if I'm if I'm saying if I'm
saying how can I have children if I
don't got a wife okay that's different
that's different than how could he have
children that's what it says no how
could he have
children this is crazy that's in front
of you
bro on wait wait let let him let him
finish his thought what okay so what
does it mean because you repeated the
same thing but you you weren't allowed
to conclude so what does that mean okay
fine if you said it then what what
what's the meaning there's there was
never no he doesn't need a mate there
was never no mate for him to need to
have to make to create so the meaning so
you're claiming the meaning is he's
saying he doesn't need a mate yes that's
that's exactly what I'm saying wow so so
him saying so so Allah saying as a
refuge
to people saying he has a son he says
how can I do this if I don't have A's
not saying he's not saying how can I
saying how could he have children when
there's no wife there's
no no but what the verse
said listen to what he just said he just
told me that it's not he didn't say how
can I and then when he opened his mouth
that's exactly what he said no saying
how could he have children when there
when he has no M no wait life he's
saying this look look so so he's missing
so he's he's missing the the complete
premise he's thinking he's thinking
we're saying something else about the
verse that we're not actually saying the
Crux of the argument is is God all
powerful the Quran says if he's all
powerful um the the the question then
becomes if he is all powerful because
you would obviously say yes the Quran
then say say there is something that he
actually cannot do so therefore how can
you be all powerful if you cannot do
this the Quran says how can he have a
wife I mean how can he have a son if he
does not have a wife this is something
that Allah cannot do therefore Allah is
not all powerful making him not God
that's the argument saying is not saying
he needs a wife to have I don't even
know what else to say at this point
crazy that's it all right habbi man I I
appreciate your attitude man as was I I
enjoyed you know you were respectful I
enjoyed the back and forth I'mma go
ahead and and try someone else man to
see if they can if they want to
contribute all right all right man how
can I you
stupid
wow manifest bro that's manifesting at
his finest hey bring
[Applause]
up hey me what you do what you do BR he
was talking to me yeah Oh I thought he
said life you stupid he wasn't talking
to me you said I mean he was talking hey
I know he was talking damn I guess I'm
stupid I'm oh wait wait wait hold on I'm
stupid yet the Quran claims in several
places that Allah appar well according
to you Muslims Allah La is all powerful
but apparently when we're reading a
verse verbatim and we're interpreting it
correctly we're the St ones but you guys
can't read make that make sense bro so
yeah I I guess I'm stupid if I'm stupid
then what does that make you if I mean
stupid I'm stupid too that's wild he
said Allah ask him how can he do
something if he doesn't have something
means that he doesn't need that to do it
so if you so so if you say if you say as
a reputation of people saying you drove
the car and you say how can I drive that
car when I don't have the keys that's
basically you saying you can drive the
car without the
keys we're stupid for just reading it
saying you don't need the keys it's it's
it's always the complete opposite of
what we think it is in Islam you got to
remember that that wouldn't mean that
the Quran is a stupid book though by the
way I'm just saying because if we're
just reading it and then you guys come
up and say no it doesn't mean that it
means make a left hand turn on I 85 when
you get to Exit 32 and we're like wait
where you getting that from and you guys
are like no it says that that's what it
means when Allah right when Allah says
go right he really means go left go left
yeah okay yeah and we're the stupid ones
okay no problem